it's gotta be
this is
awesome just this introduction
oh
that voice is very familiar and who
might you be
oh yeah that's it
he is terrifying i was never this yeah
oh his teeth are so sharp who's paying
you will match
the way they are doing cat is so good
and let things play out what a freaking
badass marshall for sale i was never
this afraid of cad in the animated
series this guy is living breathing
terror it's terrifying deputy do not get
messed up in this fight go back inside
you're gonna you don't know
no one knows you yet you know the name
yet yeah
yeah wait for your name to be uttered so
you can become candid
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] oh they did such a good job i
don't know how they can do this first
ahsoka now this guy making these uh
these other alien races
his eyes tommy
what did you do to his eyes
is that friendly advice or a threat he
looks awesome he looks awesome
i will give you a choice okay
but what else
frogs more frogs
jacket or a gun
[Laughter]
it's like when you're trying to trick a
kid into taking a bath like that's right
take a bath or you go to bed right now
we could go to bed with nothing and they
choose
[Music]
at least let him try it let him try it
on at least i mean girl could just
snatch the dark might just snatch the
lightsaber and then turn the master loop
with it and then you get it
that's right
that's the rule of two that's how you do
it
yeah
this is some real childhood divorce [ __ ]
welcome back to new rockstars the book
of boba fett's cast just grows wider and
wider with mando reuniting with luke
skywalker on the show old family friend
ahsoka tano grogu cobb banff cad freakin
bane at this point we could only hope
boba fett might cameo in this boba fett
series
what the [ __ ] that
sorry i was off on that just because i
i'm still so stunned from this everyone
is back and everyone's just talking i
don't know how to process all this i
feel spoiled but i'm enjoying it for
sure this is wikileaks it's new
rockstar's book of boba fett after show
our weekly reaction to the latest in
star wars and what a night of star wars
this was everyone's here i'm eric voss
my easter egg breakdown is coming out
tomorrow but right now i am here with
tommy bechtold tommy thoughts on this
episode oh my god i was i mean every
second of it unpacked another revelation
and uh
and an introduction into this specific
show from old characters elements of
westerns elements of mafia movies
elements of just flat out classic star
wars it was i don't know we're really
spoiled yeah i think spoiled is the best
way to feel because i'll tell you
several times during watching this
episode i was like did they accidentally
like leak the wrong episode to us like
i mean this is not at all the same show
as boba fett and the dunesy with tuscans
this is a totally different this is even
like spoiling for i didn't think we
would see this kind of stuff on the
mandalorian until like season four
season five so the fact that they're
just throwing it all at us now just it
makes me feel like it makes me feel like
this is the last we're going to see of
luke skywalker for a while that they had
to get in
they had to pay that off of spending a
lot of time with grogu learning from
luke learning from the master at this
point in history
because realistically that is not the
future for grogu the future is at
mando's side and they realize that they
had to do that that's the core dynamic
of the mandalorian series and they can't
have a whole season of the mandalorian
where these two are separated so instead
they kind of awkwardly sandwich it in to
this just kind of like filler uh season
i'm not gonna say filler season because
so much more than filler has happened
but really it's just like a placeholder
season where it's like oh we can get
that done in the seven episodes of the
book of boba fett even though they have
nothing to do with boba fett or his
journey
but they know we won't complain i'm not
complaining
the opposite i quite frankly i'd be like
if you want to just do like you know ten
more episodes of this i mean if anything
we could just maybe they wanted to
preserve the surprise but what was so
surprising about seeing luke with with
groga we all knew that at some point
they were gonna go learn from each other
uh you could just have another like four
to five episode miniseries of just luke
and grogu you know
i'd watch or make a just a movie that
you drop and you can make an event of it
like make an event of seeing luke with
grogu
building this jedi school ahsoka tano
shows up talks about anakin we all cry
when we hear the yoda theme come back i
know
oh my god it's it's so yeah this is i
think the the last we might see of of
luke skywalker for a while i mean he
might show up in the finale i guess i'd
be surprised he'll show up here and
there but this is meant to be
yeah finally groga gets his time with
luke skywalker because really he's just
going back to dinger inside that's
absolutely where where
freaking belongs yeah where he belongs
yes where he belongs uh let's recap what
happened this episode so it actually
opens with cobb bath returning timothy
olefin just getting a great acting
moment here
dressing down these pikes moving spice
in his territory tough but fair he's
willing to let them walk away he knows
what they were doing but this guy he
said he's got this hamster damn policy
right like i didn't see it i don't know
what's in that camp dodo i didn't see
what's in that chest you just you'd go
your way but you know what they had to
the pikes are feeling strong my friend
yeah they and they flexed at a gun fight
and they lost but that one does get away
with the warning you know you got to
send the message uh and i love how he
kicks over this box of spice to just get
lost in the wind yeah he wants to get it
off the street he honestly felt like did
this guy used to be a spice addict
himself and he's like no i've seen the
darkness what this can do to you i'm not
going down this throw it again
he calls his sponsor and his sponsor's
like i'm proud of you
oh he just goes on a bender he's just
sitting in a crate dragons like rotting
corpse bam bam bam bam bam bam bam bam
baby
some jaw was coming with a shot of a
drone just crying
but you know he he kicks over that box
of spice you know there's some tuscans
downwind from there who are like ah this
is weak [ __ ] yeah
if this yeah if this doesn't wriggle up
your nose and send you to a magical tree
we don't want it so amanda tracks down
the planet where luke took groku and we
learn has been building the same jedi
school the same school that's gonna get
wrecked when ben solo defects from luke
that we saw in the last jedi flashback
and this maybe it's because you're
trusting the construction to some ant
droids now i i yes in our world ants are
very industrious little beings they have
short life spans and they're able to
build entire colonies out of that and
ant bed so good on them yes but luke
didn't oversee it himself and they built
it they built it pretty freaking fast so
maybe yeah talking out of turn this
suggests the existence of a space dave
matthews singing oh the little droid
ants are marching
yeah
we could have that i like that uh i i
dave matthews exists in every universe
right we just haven't found him yet but
he's there are over one million possible
dave matthews is over a million
universes
just a million though the rest are
playing are hoping to be session
guitarists with the next revo band but
they go the night the place gets blown
up
well r2 guy they built him a bench which
is so nice of them they're like this
guy's wearing a lot of armor he should
sit uh and r2 just takes a nap he's like
look this is nap time you got a bench
i'm just powering down for a bit i wish
i could do that yeah me too
luke skywalker returns this episode with
grogu meditating and tommy let's just
stop and appreciate this we get a lot of
luke skywalker in this episode more than
i ever thought we would see d aged mark
hamill in live action maybe it's just
because they hired that vfx artist who
did a way better version of it on
youtube they lucasfilm did hire that guy
and maybe they're like all right we got
the best let's do it and i think they
were smarter about it this time they
showed most of luke's dialogue off
screen in a wide shot they had fewer
close-ups of just his lower uh chin and
mouth moving which is where that uncanny
valley gets triggered and uh and it
sounded like mark hamill was doing the
voice again but it did sound like maybe
they had coached mark hamill to do uh
just more stoic line reads so that they
would have to do less emoting on the
face for this i mean can we just like
admit whatever your thoughts are on
whether whether this is just straight-up
nostalgia porn or whether this is true
to what the the overall story of boba
fett is in this series
i can never blame star wars for just
cashing in on this because it works it
works on me of a a man of a certain
generation just to hear the yoda theme
you know
there's a magic to that
why not cash in on who knows how long
star wars is going to popular be popular
in pop culture you have this toy just
play with it sure and i and i understand
that coming out of uh the mandalorian
season two we do feel a need of just
seeing
luke teach grogu we need to feel that
dagobah vibe of training this this child
giving him a chance say his say yoda's
name say yoda's name more and more and
more ahsoka did so that was huge but the
i i really did truly love hearing all
the music i i've seen luke front
flipping through a jungle you know all
that stuff just really does just put me
a place where i don't care what you're
doing that much i i would have preferred
maybe seeing uh grogu's training his
jedi training be a bit
harder on him you know seeing him
balk at it a bit more uh and i'm
basically giving acting notes to a
puppet i understand
but it would have been great to have one
moment where like it's painful for grogu
to go through the training it just
seemed like it was annoying to him it
was exhausting to him um but other than
that one order 66 uh flashback uh we
don't really see how it's like maybe
it's not best for grogu to go through
this jedi training uh that it might be a
better path for him um but i do like how
this episode ends setting up the the
choice for him right but a groku gets
distracted by a frog now i gotta say
there are some medications for that but
uh luke prevents him from eating the
frog but also teaches them by masculine
the force that you can lift all the
frogs out of the water so listen to me i
can get you all the frogs you want kid i
also like how luke was not very it
seemed not very patient with groga as
they were doing their walk and talk he's
just like come on kind of using the
force to whoosh him forward toward it
like hurry up dragging the leash let's
go it was like i'm not here
like a parent at disney like come on i'm
just gonna pick you up all right let's
go let's go let's go
and yeah he talks all about master yoda
how yoda talked how he's spoken riddles
uh and luke uses the force to help
grosgu remember the night of order 66
when the 501 clone troopers killing
three jedi right in front of a young
grogu but we don't get the full story
yet we don't see exactly how grogo
escaped what happened when those clone
troopers got close to him where exactly
he was hidden because it looked like he
was still inside of something right he
was peering out through through kind of
a an eye hole sort of um i have some
thoughts on that later but uh amanda
wakes up to find a socatano because it
wasn't enough to have luke skywalker in
this episode we also need rosario dawson
as ahsoka tano now she makes it clear
she's not there to help train grogu it's
like she had to kind of justify like
this is why i'm in this episode i know i
said i didn't want to train kroku but uh
you know they decided that i also needed
to be here to remind fans that i exist
and to blow everyone's minds but uh she
says that grogu has been doing fine here
really it's the safest place in the
galaxy to be and i agree i think right
now most people would agree being at
luke skywalker's side is really the
safest place to be and amanda says that
he wants to make sure grog is just okay
and to give him this gift uh and she
asked an important question are you
doing this for grogu are you doing this
for yourself and she questions his use
of the term foundling um and she says is
it gonna be a family or is he going to
be a padawan like what's the proper term
for student here but she says that i'll
give him the gift you can get out of
here because
him seeing you is just going to make
things more difficult which is true as
you go through jedi training it forces
you to detach from all bonds with uh
people that you love and i think like
uh we do get a little moment of that too
with with grogu when he reaches out for
the starfighter i think he he is feeling
a bit of pain from having to seclude
himself from from those he loved and
yeah we get a lot of parallels this
episode they're just a delight uh
parallels with obi-wan training luke on
the falcon and a new hope with the
training remote and you feel kind of bad
for groga it's like you didn't even know
that was coming at least luke had a
lightsaber to try to deflect the bolts
with poorer poor grogu just like the
hell is this thing i understand why he
destroys it just drowns it he's like
yeah he's like
kidding me yeah well we also get some uh
some memories of yoda training luke on
dagobah balancing over the swamp doing
front flips of the rocks wearing grogu
as a backpack bjorn it was just like of
course you travel around with with him
and that like it's just so sweet i love
it
um we also get some moments with luke
and ahsoka ahsoka reminding luke that
she knew his father she calls herself an
old family friend in this episode which
i think is just perfect and luke wonders
at the end of all this if grogu's heart
is really in it but we get a little bit
of reminder that this is the book of
boba fett when mando heads back to mos
espa to join boba fett we see the whole
team this really ragtag team not an army
including boba dave squeazy coming back
as a major domo blacker stanton the mods
of course infinix shand and now mando
joins a team uh and they say that the
three local crime families have already
yielded to the pike syndicate finnick
lament said if it's gonna be all about
war they're gonna be woefully
outnumbered mando enlisted he has some
more firepower that he knows of on this
planet and he goes to a ranch town of
reluctant farmers uh to get some backup
are we sure these are the best warriors
do you know of mando on this planet or
anywhere well at first he does fly right
back by that jawa sand crawler with the
freaking crate dragon skull on top of it
i love that at first says like are you
gonna recruit jawas to fight in this war
because yeah it's gonna be fun yeah but
no so he goes to montipelgo which is now
renamed freetown they're the three-time
people are worried but cop band is like
i'll see what i can do and as we way bar
keep of course played by timothy the
olympian's former deadwood co-star w
earl brown uh loves the angel
but a huge moment this episode my
favorite cameo this episode honestly
figure with a bridge here's the horizon
true
true carradine
from the horizon struttin up man what an
introduction the titular uh from the
desert came a stranger right of this
episode
cad freaking bane
the uh badass
bounty hunter from the clone wars
animated series who just popped up here
in there a terrifying figure who really
arose in the period after jango fett
and seen him in live action i mean i
suspected how they had the dent in boba
fett's helmet and in the clone wars
unfinished arc it was cad cad bane who
did that i thought we might see him on
the show but the way he looks
he's voiced by voice actor corey burton
who is just he does the voice of like
disney and a lot of stuff you know uh
like if you're in disney resorts if you
hear a voice a lot of times it's just
cory burton this guy has such a great
voice for these kind of things i was
terrified by seeing cad paint and just
he's clearly now aligned with the pikes
right
yeah gets in this classic western
standoff and the way this is edited it's
just classic it's beautiful it's tense
my heart is pounding i don't know which
way it's gonna go so he ends up doing a
quick draw on the deputy it's just
triggered by that stupid deputy right if
you just stayed out of it who knows what
would have happened uh but really it's
uh i think the reason it went that way
is cad bane knew that cobb wasn't gonna
uh shoot at him as uh fatally it's
really he's like i gotta send a message
to this deputy i need i need uh cobb
bath to uh to send this message to be
the trusted leader uh because he already
began this episode pretty isolationist
and i think had bane respects that and
he needs someone who's going to be less
of a gunslinger to deliver this message
shoots him in the shoulder i think
combat is okay so uh in the following
scene a a pair of pikes stopped by
gossip whip sanctuary do not stay for
the drinks i was wondering where is max
rebo right now
this guy
knows that he's got an inside source of
which shit's about to go down so he is
nev he always survives yeah
he you know he showed up late and with
his like keyboard rolling in he's like
oh no
i'm gonna find another bit i got another
drummer uh
uh well poor gossip whip i thought there
was gonna be more uh to her i thought
she was gonna be revealed as she was
just there to be fridged and to die i
don't know is that a proper use of
phrygian i don't know enough about it i
should just stop using terms that i
haven't done enough
self-education on anyway well finally we
return to luke and grogu where they're
in they've completed this school pretty
quickly it seems like he unwraps this
gift and confirms that it is best guard
chain mail knee thrill style chain mail
it's beautiful but luke says ah before
you take this i got another choice for
you gives him a lightsaber wielded by
master yoda perfect it seemed the
symmetry's there the poetry is perfect
he must choose one does he want to be a
jedi or does he want to be a mandalorian
what will the choice be i have a pretty
good idea i love that we end on this
choice uh i mean it's a pretty wild hour
of television
well we're going to talk about what
choice grogu probably will make going
ahead and what that says about this
series as a whole but first this week is
one of your last chances to get this
boba inspired latest obsession shirt
over at new rockstarsmerch.com it's a
really cool limited edition design that
they're about to send back to the
starlock pit for good so grab one quick
when you buy the shirt you'll get the
chance to leave a custom shout out that
will appear at the bottom of these
wikileaks episodes let's see we got uh
john who says i believe that kyber
crystal inside the darksaber is fully
connected to him and that makes it heavy
feeling uh by him i assume you mean din
jaren oh so like the more like he kind
of crossed the valley and now he's he's
too connected with the kyber crystal and
that makes it heavy that's an
interesting take on it that uh that yeah
i i i think
the opposite personally i think den
jiren has no connection with that kyber
crystal he is just carrying it for now
because he doesn't trust anyone else to
carry it he doesn't want it to end up in
the wrong hands because his dark saber
always ends up in the wrong hands it's
destined to
um let's see christian says what
character from clone wars or rebels
would you like to see in live action it
seems like we're getting all of them
right at this point
the bucket list is pretty thin
i would say it's someone who we aren't
expecting to show up necessarily i would
love to see rex show up in this finale i
think right yeah it'd be so fun to see
tomorrow morrison play one of those
other
uh one of those other clone troopers
from animated or someone from the bad
match you know i think that would be
really cool
i i always want to hear tommy's lyrics
instead of what the actual lyrics are
all right tommy what's our question
coming out of this episode oh eric let
me just ask you real quick what the fat
will grow goo choose i'm gonna give you
a short answer in case you want to stop
watching this episode grogu has already
chosen to be a mandalorian family and he
doesn't need yoda's lightsaber because
this little kid's gonna wield the
darksaber that's it bye bye everyone oh
wait no we can't leave now there's so
much more to talk about tommy there were
two clear moments this episode that took
us inside of grogu's mind beyond the
physical delights of him hopping away
from training remotes riding on luke's
back uh using the force to snack on
frogs really the moments where we
started to learn about where grogu's
mind is at right now the first of course
is when luke tried to help him remember
the night of his escape from the jedi
temple on the night of order 66 and this
was pretty scary it looked as though
groga was still peering out from inside
of some container as three jedi defended
him from the 501st battalion of clone
troopers two of these jedi were hooded
we couldn't really see but the middle
looked older had light hair tied in a
bun and my first thought was like whoa
whoa whoa librarian jocasta new no no no
i thought i thought maybe but you know
no sticks in the bun and uh this jedi's
hair was blonde not silver and he let he
let a man scream when he got hit this
episode's audio description called him a
male uh so i'll try to figure out who
exactly this is in the breakdown uh but
it's not jocasta but after all three of
these jedi fall the clone troopers
advance toward grogu and then the memory
suddenly ends with groga waking up in a
completely different location than he
was before we still don't know exactly
what happened to grogu on that night and
who might have saved him from these
clone troopers and snuck him out of the
temple though the timing of this does
confirm that it probably was not obi-wan
kenobi or yoda they didn't arrive in the
temple until the next morning after all
the jedi were killed and then they
cleared out the clone troopers who were
occupying it uh so now tommy my money is
on mace windu who survived the attack
from
palpatine
crawled his way over to the jedi temple
and i i if you think what other
characters left from the prequel era who
we need to see is his era if not samuel
l jackson right yeah i assume that like
uh both samuel jackson emilia clarke's
contracts on secret invasion there's a
there's a star wars clause in there like
also if we need you to suit up i also
think it's still possible that r2d2
could have toted out grosgood's diet
storage unit
uh because anakin was there slaughtering
the other young lanes i think you know
that could have been the container that
groga was peering out he could have been
witnessing these three jedi get killed
in front of r2 and when the clone
troopers were pointing this direction
they really just point at the direction
of this astromech droid and they're like
this way and then they run past r2 not
knowing that grog is inside that could
totally be plausible still but the fact
that groga was still so haunted by this
jedi memory i think tells us a lot and i
think we also have to recognize the
irony that luke skywalker is now trying
to heal grogu of the trauma that luke's
father caused this is a direct
connection here uh but the other moment
of course is when mando's n1 starfighter
departs this planet and grogo reaches
his hand out toward the starfighter at
first just seems like you know a young
toddler reaching out to something he
wants
but this is also a force sensitive being
who seemed like he was trying to channel
his force sensitivity into force pulling
this ship to keep it grounded and to
keep his most beloved figure in his life
so ultimately yes i think grogu is still
just too haunted by the glow of a green
lightsaber that night to see another
green lightsaber now i think freaks them
out uh even if it is master yoda's
lightsaber i don't think he understands
the significance of it i think to him
it's more comforting
to go for the best guard in heathrow uh
i think to to groku every time he's seen
lightsabers in his life it's been a
horrific event with filled with violence
i don't think he sees it as cool i i
think he nice he likes the comfort of a
nice warm embrace of cold
basker steel clinging to his body right
i hope that is the case i will be
disappointed if groggy chooses the light
saber unless unless that ends up like
bringing grogu to this dark place of
using the lightsaber and then uh
it's like the red rider bb gun of oh you
should not have this yes or you should
or is it cute it's nice that ralphie
gets to keep his red rider bb gun at the
end of that right
boys it's okay now in yesterday's video
i broke down the full history of the
dark saber and the various options of
mandalorians who might end up wielding
this weapon but i think this show based
off of this episode is setting up grogu
to wield the darksaber and grogu like
tarvisla is really a figure with shared
custody among the jedi and the
mandalorians and it is possible that
grogu could one day be the leader who
could bring peace and life back to
mandalore the one figure who is
untouched by the corruption and the and
the envy and the darkness of the
previous history just a kid who's still
always been shielded whether it's by uh
whatever container unit he's being snuck
out of whatever egg he's floating around
in or whoever is protecting him uh
shielded from the worst of all this
world uh and might might be the one who
can clearly see the way forward uh what
do you think tommy the way we have set
up grogu in the first two seasons of
mandalorian is he's mischievous likes to
steal he likes to take things that
aren't his so choose one and then steal
the other right i think he's destined to
wield the darksaber with that amazing
best guard chainmail that maybe will get
bigger and bigger as it just stretches
out it just it's like it's the ultimate
stretch athletic wear really you know
tommy i think like i was as i was doing
through this episode after i'd watched
it i really felt like they ultimately
did it right you couldn't have grogoo's
time with luke skywalker be a complete
disaster yeah
luke still needs to have his blind faith
in the general code in the jedi order
for when he starts to teach ben solo and
and maybe you could argue grogu
rebuffing luke is what leads to luke
making the mistake of recruiting his
nephew to be a new jedi initiate what a
conflict that would create in future
kylo ren ben solo to have his own family
blood to have his uncle be his jedi
master so every time the jedi master
does something that's going to piss you
off or tell you some [ __ ] that
sounds like cult kool-aid like the fact
that it's coming from the mouth of your
uncle with all this history that's a lot
of pressure that you could argue
was part of the way ben solo was able to
be uh vulnerable to
who is it ultimately palpatine who is
corrupting him i guess we could say
well he had been every voice yes
yes
so i think this is important that it go
kind of well between between grogu and
luke skywalker you need to see like luke
skywalker still feel like if only i had
had more time with this kid yeah things
could have been great so it needed to be
it couldn't have been too disastrous i
just i i think it would have been really
effective and hopefully we learned more
about this from groku hopefully we see
more of the night from order 66 where it
was really uh it was already pretty
traumatic but i just i need to see uh i
need a peek inside grog whose head that
tells us that specifically jedi training
is something that is bad for him wow
i think i think dave filoni and jon
favreau who co-wrote this episode dave
felony directed it of course robert
rodriguez executive producer of the show
i think uh they all had this difficult
task of returning to luke skywalker at
this point in history who is not yet the
jaded scarred figure that he is in the
last jedi uh because it needs to be ben
solo's defection that causes that
outlook uh he still kind of has um the
zen mindset that he got from the death
of his father the way he processed that
uh and his optimism to rebuild the jedi
order um but they need to show that
positive era that hope of rebuilding the
jedi way
um while still depicted as something
that is not good for grogu uh and that's
difficult to do you know when i grow up
i want to be a jedi i want like that's
what and now it's not maybe the most
desirable or fun to be a jedi you know
it's a great burden well we'll talk more
about this we got to talk about cad bane
right that's a big cameo this episode
but before we get to him we want to
thank hellofresh for sponsoring this
episode they may not be shipping out
grilled banana kebabs straight from the
dunes of tatooine but our friends at
hellofresh are shipping out farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes right to your doorstep their
pork and chicken certainly taste better
than banta anyways and you know there's
probably little grains of sand in those
kebabs hellofresh delivers pre-portioned
ingredients to your door including farm
fresh produce that arrives within a week
so you get convenience without skimping
on quality skip the trip to the grocery
store saving you the weight in long
lines and ensuring you don't waste money
on excess food customize your favorite
dishes with their new hello custom
offerings by swapping out one protein or
side for another upgrading for a more
luxe experience or even adding protein
to a veggie meal that means more choices
more variety and more meals truly
tailored to you we are big fans of
hellofresh in our house great excuse to
try cooking new things in a way that
sets us up for success the food is
always tasty and i feel an extra sense
of accomplishment for cooking something
new so go to hellofresh.com
wikileaks16 and use code wookieleeks16
for up to 16 free meals and three free
gifts all right tommy what's our next
question who the fat is cat bae and who
is he working for now yes cad bane now
if you didn't watch the animated series
shame on you you have no excuse not to
not watch everything get started that's
right android growed up with all these
shows did you get all the references no
that's why you come here we're going to
remind you of who this guy is so cad
bane is a major bounty hunter figure
who's active during the clone wars and
showed up throughout the clone wars
animated series he really of course came
to prominence after jango fett's death
django fed a dying and attack of the
clones which is at the beginning of the
clone wars that's when it began cadbane
shows up in a hostage plot on coruscant
that was really designed to freeze zero
the hut he did this on behalf of the
other huts zero the hut the most
annoying voice i think i've heard in any
animated show ever i hate the way this
character sounds i always watch it on
mute and just watch it on subtitles when
zero the hud starts talking
i hate zero the hut with a fiery passion
one of the more interesting plots
involved with was with sidious uh in the
securement of a holocron that sidious
wanted to use to uh find force sensitive
kids to build a sith army to screw the
jedi over of course didn't work i was
just interested how he was involved with
that he was also involved in a
separatist plot to assassinate palpatine
not knowing that he is the same guy uh
but that was another multi-episode plot
he he showed up in these like uh plots
that took three to four episodes to kind
of to deal with and of course he showed
up on bad batch in the most recent
season last year he kidnapped omega for
the kamino and so we're trying to get
her back in a camino uh and
most important perhaps to this series in
the unfinished clone wars episodes it
was going to be cadbane in a duel with
boba fett that was responsible for the
dent in boba's helmet will that be the
case now because the dent is still there
in live action i think why not filoni
produced all those episodes you know
this guy's going to be like yeah let's
make that canonically true that's where
we got it we know that cad bain is now
working on behalf of the pikes but is it
just going to be the pikes is there
anybody behind the pikes is there room
for anyone else on this show at this
point no we were kind of waiting for
some more interesting villainous cameo
to uh appear as a threat to to boba fett
now it really seems like cad bane is
filling that role someone from the past
who we've been wanting to see in live
action again uh and he is working on
behalf of the pikes and then the real
threat to boba fett i wonder if we'll
get the duel and that duel will be
considered a rematch between these
characters i feel that's inevitable at
this point they're on a collision course
for each other but it's also the like
the the interesting thing about a show
about bounty hunters and performed
bounty hunters is they're all just for
hire if uh cad bane if they duel and
then ultimately he ends up working with
boba i don't know you know i'm not sure
who knows all i know is they have a lot
to pack into the last episode absolutely
a lot uh i don't know if they're gonna
resolve all of it i i i don't know
honestly
do we care that much about getting the
pikes off a tattooing i understand why
it's important all these characters but
over these past
two episodes have they really done a lot
to make us care and make us worry about
the pikes i would say cad bane as an
individual i'm more worried about cad
bane as a person now in this world
because he's terrifying i want to see
his spin-off he brought in the bounty
hunter fear that we have felt
occasionally fermando but as soon as we
started to get to know mando that you
know kind of went out the window he was
a daddy now but just reminding us how
scary bounty hunters can be when they
step into your town they've made him
terrifying they made his introduction
super scary he kills the deputy oh
ostensibly we're pretty sure he kills
the deputy i don't necessarily need
anything to be resolved
this season well our final question we
should ask is uh if the people of moscow
go don't join boba in his fight against
the pikes who will be his army you and
what army boba and who do you think
might join boba at his side now you know
i just can't help but have this image in
my head of a bunch of pikes
staring at
a little group of bob's crime family
when i when all of a sudden you hear
like a
and here comes that warrior tuscan
raider and she's assembled other tuscan
raiders that's what i think yeah that's
that's my hope that's if we hear like
the the rokharim right i want it to be
the tuscans on banthas right or or just
like a wave of uh the massives or
whatever that are coming over the over
the crest but uh i think that's one
great option that would totally feel
like oh it was worth it to see those
first few episodes his relationship and
this is why uh i think that's the best
option for sure i think it's also
possible that part of that uh that
alliance could be some other clone
setter out there uh whoever's left of
the bad batch omega rex would be
freaking cool to see show up here um so
maybe there's just like some other
clones that are out there that still
want to help him out that he may not
know exists but someone else might hook
him up uh i still think the tuscans are
really the family i want to see come to
his aid historically in star wars at
least animated bokeh tan is usually the
one who just shows up randomly to help
kick ass right this could be a way you
get other mandalorians and that whole
quest to the dark saber more tied into
this finale very possible i would say
all of them please
yes they say on your left
[Music]
well we will see uh that we have one
more episode left what an insane season
this has been we went from having not
enough star wars interconnectivity to
having probably a bit too much star wars
interconnectivity but i'm not gonna
complain i i'm the goldilocks who eats
all three bowls and doesn't let anyone
else get a bite greedy little goldie
well that is it for this episode of
wikileaks again my easter egg breakdown
is coming tomorrow and tommy and i will
be back next wednesday with our reaction
to the finale of the book of boba fett
and not only will we be back next
wednesday if you are in chicago we will
be in your town on friday february 11th
doing a special live new rockstar show
8pm february 11th italia hall it's gonna
be me and tommy and jessica clements and
philip molina we're gonna be doing
something weird and wacky and fun
something we have never done on the
channel before so if you're in the
chicago area it's a great opportunity to
come meet us get to know us we'd love to
meet you so don't forget to check out
our many great merch options at
rockstarsmerch.com follow me at ea boss
follow tommy at tommybechto follow the
rockstars subscribe to wikileaks
wherever you get your podcasts thank you
for watching and we have spoken
[Music]
[Music]
you